il aime usa team celle d'avec le sien
dufour bonsoir ça je veux revenir sur
les sondages quand même le léger
aujourd'hui qui confirme ce que les
autres disaient depuis maintenant trois
quatre jours certainement le nas le men
street et c'est que les conservateurs
sont passés devant regarde le tableau
rapidement intentions de vote au canada
les conservateurs qui sont premiers à 34
pour ça les libéraux à 30 le et le npd à
24 c pour le canada au québec ça bouge
mais un peu moins alors tour de table
helen
levitt dans les projections de sièges
fait avec les chiffres d'aujourd'hui
manquent pas de majorité monsieur trudel
on se demande s'ils voient même une
victoire
vous vous êtes exclamé toute à leur
patrie ça avec votre bon sens qui nous a
tous un peu fair et je dirais que je
pense que monsieur trudeau lui il
utilise les mots un peu pire
en ce moment quand il voit ses chiffres
écoutez il faisait une livraison sont
vos atouts pour aller chercher une
majorité ou op être reconduit au pouvoir
et là il se pourrait très réaliste le
mans que le pouvoir lui glisse entre les
mains alors c'est évidemment pas ce
qu'il espérait évidemment le vote
libéral il est plus efficace que celui
des conservateurs qui se trouve à être
plus concentrés dans certaines régions
notamment l'alberta donc il ya encore un
petit avantage pour le parti libéral
mais là tout est possible il reste
encore trois semaines les débats
monsieur trudeau on la vit pas mal plus
compliquée que ce qu'il pensait quand il
a déclenché le 15 août dernier ouais
michel david c'est en tout cas puis on
ne s'est pas fait soyons prudents parce
que d'abord les libéraux comme disent
comme dit hélène peuvent être plus
efficaces le npd peu baissé juste avant
les gens vont aux rg on n'a pas envie
d'un gouvernement conservateur non plus
oui c'est un peu ce qui peut arriver ça
veut dire que ça va arriver mais c'est
arrivé dans le passé et on voit une des
questions de légers c'est la suivante si
ça devient très serré à la fin ce que
vous seriez plus enclins à voter pour
les libéraux ou pour les conservateurs
il ya plus de mouvements possibles vers
les libéraux que vers les conservateurs
ceci étant dit monsieur trudeau je pensé
et lui même largement responsables de
durée du piétinement de son parti parce
que dans le fond
pourra enfin il est presque au même
niveau qu'en 2009 ce sont les
conservateurs c'est à dire non il perdre
un peu de poids mais les conservateurs
ne font pas vraiment de progrès ils font
le plein de leur vol mais quand je dis
que c'est la faute de monsieur trudeau
c'est quand on demande aux gens est-ce
que depuis une semaine l'image de
monsieur trudeau et de tous les autres
chefs s'est améliorée ou s'est
détériorée selon vous et 41% disent que
l'image qu'ils ont de monsieur trudeau
s'est détériorée et seulement 7% que
s'est améliorée d'un canot s'est auto
c'est à peu près équivalent à 24,23 qui
sont soit moins compte enduits ou plus
content alors monsieur trudeau là
comment dire un examen de conscience à
faire c'est beaucoup de lui damas le
chef du parti c'est normal mais sa
performance je pense déçoit beaucoup de
jeunes qui siens bah c'est une autre
preuve que les campagnes électorales
change beaucoup les choses parce
qu'avant le déclenchement des élections
le gouvernement libéral semble avoir des
chances sérieuses d'être majoritaire bon
tant que c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
seul sondage qui compte c'est le jour de
l'élection oui ces réserves étant est en
fait monsieur trudeau semble avoir perdu
son pari parce que c'est un secret de
polichinelle que la seule région refaite
de la direction s'était d'abord un
gouvernement majoritaire carlos a
cependant exclu en définitive est-ce que
ça va être un gouvernement minoritaire
libéral-conservateur soir que son enjeu
donc il joue quand même son gouvernement
sa majorité poursuit sa carrière
politique personnelle parce que ces sont
des chèques à lui et moi je prévois que
la campagne commence à peine tout compte
fait ça va être féroce finale l'observer
de vicieux parce que les libéraux se
laisseront pas bête domaine dont il faut
s'attendre vraiment à des attaques
vraiment très très intenses je sais pas
si vous avez remarqué que depuis
vendredi je trudeau a changé de ton pris
part
m vous suivez beaucoup vous payer les
manifestations ils commencent à faire
des déclarations non scriptée un peu
plus senties on a l'impression que que
qui prend la mesure du combat violent
qui mène s'il veut même rester
minoritaire oui on j'ai senti
effectivement qu'il y a plusieurs à
plusieurs reprises il est sorti du
script si vous me passez l'expression
l'heure on sent qu'ils parlent librement
sans lire ses notes et c'est ce qu'il a
toujours servi mais depuis plusieurs
années il ya depuis qu'il est premier
ministre il s'est enfoncé dans cette
façon de donner un peu de manière
presque robotique lol et toujours les
même lignée et du fait que ça fait
dix-sept mois qu'on l'entend il ya
peut-être une certaine lassitude qui
s'est installée dans l'électorat et donc
peut-être que sa survie va passer par sa
de redevenir un petit peu plus
authentique parle un peu plus avec le
coeur mais je dirais que ça serait aussi
vrai pour monsieur o'toole qui lui aussi
suit beaucoup inscrits et que n'est pas
particulièrement ce cas le châssis
d'accord avec michel la queue que c'est
pas tant que monsieur otto les nous
impressionnent que monsieur trudeau qui
déçoit il a réussi michel et christiane
surtout une chose c'est de ne pas faire
peur en tout cas n'impressionne pas me
fait pas peur une chaîne oui oui c'est
tout à fait juste même s'il ya des
éléments qui pourraient être effrayant
la dent dans son parti mais jusqu'à
présent ce soit sur l'avortement
l'environnement c'est déjà un petit peu
moins évident que monsieur otto il est
capable de livrer quelques marchandises
que ce soit mais sur la médecine privée
par exemple ça ça peut lever beaucoup et
quand je regarde d'ailleurs le sondage
de légers quand on demande aux gens ce
que vous seriez d'accord pour qu'il y
ait plus de médecine de privé dans la
santé et c'est très majoritairement oui
à condition bien entendu que lille y ait
toujours un système public disponible
mais c'est foutrement 10 a pas eu les
faits la
épouvantail que monsieur trudeau pouvait
souhaiter
maintenant une chose que monsieur ton de
monsieur trudeau et peut-être surpris je
pense qu'ils pensaient vraiment
capitaliser beaucoup surtout ce que le
gouvernement avait son gouvernement de
faire pendant la pandémie et il ya une
des questions de légers où on demande à
ce que vous vous trouvez que c'est la
bonne façon il faudrait continuer comme
ça ou s'il faudrait trouver une autre
orientation pour l'appelant 2060 2%
disent non ça prendrait autre chose quoi
je pense que des gens de sa peau
beaucoup mais il me suit trudeau je
pense fait moins de gains avec sa
gestion de la pandémie qu'il aurait pu
penser et je pense que c'est pas
tellement que les gens savent quoi lui
reprocher mais les gens sont tellement
tanné de la pandémie l'appui qu'ils
voient qu'on n'en sort pas ça se reflète
dans la mls de l'institut delà il ya
beaucoup de chats peut-être qu'on attend
autour alesi christian cette importance
que michel ce que les gens sont
tellement tanné de la pandémie que
monsieur trudeau est associé à la
famille et ça ça vaut aussi pour
monsieur legault c'est qu'on voit que le
contexte monde et milk était proprement
exceptionnels et les premiers ministres
qui étaient là en fait tous les jours on
y voyait on seraient liées derrières
vieux c'était très naturel très normal
mais quand on arrive dans une campagne
électorale c'est complètement autre
chose pour revenir à monsieur hôtelier
très très difficile à diaboliser ça
tellement été essayées là de dire qu'ils
conservateurs c'est effrayant ça mais
quand même frappé que michel dit qu'ils
avaient encore des affaires effrayant
sous ce beau coup shell effrayant comme
on est surtout quand en jeu en fait ça
sans bet est ce qu'on va voir un
gouvernement minoritaire libéral avec
trudeau qui nous rappelle la pandémie ou
un gouvernement minoritaire conservateur
qui sera un peu sous surveillance des
autres partis donc en fait d'un côté
pour les gens qui aiment que la
politique soit morale moi je trouve que
tu as politique c'est toujours pareil
c'est très moral en fait parce que
monsieur trudeau séance en campagne
électorale avec le sol une version
motivation d'être majoritaires ont été
capables 2 nous convainquent avait autre
chose comme ça donc une sanction n'est
pas ce qu'on comprend on verra comment
va jouer le thème de la vaccination
obligatoire ou non parce qu est-ce qu il
ya encore des manifestations
l'environnement ce que ça va jouer ou
pas ont versé sepa sepa est loin d'être
finie mais jean lapierre des gens votent
pas
avec ce qu'ils ont reçu ce qu'ils ont
reçus ils ont reçu ce temps barincou pas
mais il vote avec l'espoir de l'avenir
peut-être changer les choses et l'inde
puis tous deux incarnent la pandémie est
ce qu'on a reçu ce que les gens ont vu
dans le passé mais oui
j'allais dire parce que christian de
parle un peu mais sur la vaccination
obligatoire je pense que monsieur
trudeau il joue un jeu dangereux a
essayé de de dire qu'il n'ya que deux
options possibles ou bien on est pour la
vaccination est donc la vaccination
obligatoire
ou alors on est contre la vaccination
obligatoire et donc on est sûrement
contre la vaccination contre les mesures
sanitaires on est un peu un
conspirationniste on est déchaîné hurle
à bolton je sens dans le regard de crise
et après je pas tout seul à dire ça
il fera je veux parler oui aller
j'allais juste dire je pense que c'est
un projet binaire elle ne sert pas
monsieur trudeau est justement celle
mentionnée le 62 % des gens qui veulent
une nouvelle approche dans la pandémie
eh ben je sais pas si monsieur trudeau
qu'un peut vraiment faire des points
avec cette vaccination obligatoire
compte tenu de ce chiffre dans le
sondage et françois blanchet je change
du sujet à sherbrooke avec un surf aizar
sa candidate dans sherbrooke que lui
pose drive badaoui toujours emprisonnés
en arabie saoudite
les journalistes veulent parler à la
candidate voici ce qu était
madame haidar pourquoi avoir soutenu mac
publiquement maxime dernier en 2018 je
crois pas qu'on va procéder à ces ici ce
matin madame je suis désolé donc on peut
pas interroger la candidate mais donc
vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez j'en
pense que madame haidar a eu un
cheminement qui est l'âme ligne déjà un
bon moment d'ailleurs savez pas marché
la première fois à être candidat pour le
bloc québécois vivront seulement vous
aurez l'occasion
les journalistes auront l'occasion de
poser leurs questions madame haidar est
un emblème de liberté d'égalité des
sexes de liberté d'expression de laïcité
alors emblème de liberté d'égalité des
sexes mais le chef ne la laisse pas
parler
christian je commence avec vous qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé que c'est
franchement gêne
en fait parce que j'ai l'arabie saoudite
pour qu'on a vu son parcours héroïque
cas douloureux ont eu lieu en arabie
saoudite on rabaisse les femmes
systématiquement se retrouver au canada
au québec bon là bas on la laisse pas
parler surtout qu'ensuite elle expliqué
pourquoi elle avait à muammar des
sympathies pour maxime bernier resch
défendaient très bien je trouve que
monsieur blanche est un donneur de
leçons puis là il commence à trébucher
comme donneur de leçons il ya eu aussi
ce que dit sur monsieur justin trudeau
le cancer et sans attendre que monsieur
trudeau court un peu après les problèmes
ce taux est flat station honteuse à son
égard mais écoutez moi je trouve une
grosse gaffe soit parce que l'égalité
des sexes moi je pas le genre à dire ça
d'habitude mais ce qui aurait fait ça ça
avait été un homme comme candidat
shed avec vous cette chronique cette
semaine il avait appelé le ce matin
quinze jours ou plus fin que j'ai pensé
aujourd'hui de cet épisode qui faisait
encore le smat j'ai trouvé que l'étude
de monsieur blanchet était extrêmement
maladroite d'abord c'est paternaliste
c'était éléments paternaliste à
l'endroit de sa candidate qui qui est
une candidate vedette en principe on
devrait la pousser de l'avant plutôt que
d'essayer de la cacher d'autre part
c'est comme le remarque et ça me
surprend pas mais monsieur blanchet a
toujours été très condescendant avec la
presse en direct aux pauvres et pas ce
que sont le lycée puis le papa et
troisième élément je pense que monsieur
blanchet la haie et insécure ya vapeur
d'un homme à un autre dérapage il
les troisièmes bien il ya eu bon
l'histoire avec monsieur trudeau je
trouve que monsieur blanchet est mal
placé pour traiter les autres de bavure
et là il sait ici il faut en plus leur
que ça parte là dans une direction que
keaven nuit alors je pense que monsieur
blanchet voit que le tapis commence à
glisser un peu en dessous de ses pieds
et ça le rend erratique bon il voulait
parler de laïcité aujourd'hui puis on
s'est raté parce qu'on parle de chats
parle de chats parce qu'elle y est c'est
arrivé devant nous mais oui justement
moi je vois cet épisode comme une belle
occasion ratée il voulait remettre la
laïcité à l'ordre du jour c'est un peu
sa stratégie parce qu'il sait que la
tuer puis vraiment se démarquer de son
rival principal justin trudeau au québec
madame
en 1/4 ne serait elle en parle avec
passion la laïcité elle se pose aux
voiles et
défend la loi 21 ça aurait été du bonbon
pour alimenter la note du jour de
monsieur blanchet a vraiment une
occasion très raté
je mettrai juste un petit pour parler de
monsieur autour là-dessus ce que j'ai
quand même trouvé intéressant parce que
la demande de monsieur blanchet s'est
notamment qu'on n'utilise pas l'argent
public fédéral pour financer de manière
directe ou indirecte des contestations
de la loi 21 c'est évidemment une
référence au programme canadien lot de
contestations judiciaires et monsieur au
tour aujourd'hui il le dit moi je
contesterai pas la loi maintient mais je
ne vais pas mal et des choix que ferait
le programme de contestation c'est un
programme est des grandes à
peut-être si une demande mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça vienne de
monsieur o toole rappelez vous que le
parti conservateur avait en grippe c'est
programme de contestation judiciaire ont
toujours vu ça comme une façon de
financer des idées libérales et là tout
d'un coup c'est aussi un ça fait partie
du recentrage de monsieur autour le dire
le programme qui courait qu'il faut qu
il défend très bien pour conclure son
jeu blanc chez le troisième
il ya sa
chaîne a vite voulu dit enfin vous lui
dites rien mais je devais faire une vous
constatez qu'il faut que ça qu'il faut
car être oui tout à fait je trouve que
la tendance est mal partie pour le bloc
est comme un peu comme dans le cas des
libéraux ces chefs qui est qui qui donne
le ton et le temps de monsieur blanchet
depuis quelques temps est pas agréable
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
commencent à le trouver baveux
effectivement et je vois que ces choses
ne s'arrangent pas avec le pq avez vous
déjà concevez-vous que le pq le chef du
pq témoin je me mêle pas tout non d'une
élection fédérale
le pic est alors été derrière le bloc à
100 milles à l'heure et là on s'emmêle
poste c'est se dire que la chicane de
famille de
rené lévesque avait pas qu'avant même
que ça glisse qui n'était pas chaude à
partir de là tous les chefs évidemment
appuyé le bloc qu'elle sort du four
avez-vous votre vaccin votre vaccin si
je vous n'aurez jamais ça je vous
demande le savez vous ne passez pas
vaccinale c'est demain pour le resto
vous aviez dit je vais le reste on est
tous âgés de sept passes pour cela mais
moi j'ai mes deux vaccins plus de trois
mots logis photocopier espèce de truc
avec des sessions que tu seras d'avoir
damé mêmes symptômes pour être très
franc est ce que vous êtes habitué à
l'idée réconcilier avec un emploi du
temps je me suis plus posé que j'avais
en fait ça et je pense que beaucoup de
gens qui vont être posés çà je pense à
vos cousins taux de problèmes concrets
qu'on leur faculté à appréhender et se
tait pas nécessaire comme je voyais au
contraire je suis plus dans ma position
qu'avant mais voilà ben on a une variété
de positions pour se faire enfin panel
est là michel christian merci beaucoup a
traversé et on va revoir au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit